okay I am going to give you video now of
two absolutely bonkers
speeches I guess I'm hesitating to even
call them speeches public events at
which Trump said things over the fourth
of July weekend now from the from the
perspective of rallies Donald Trump has
decided he's doing rallies he did the
rally in Tulsa Oklahoma we've already
started to see cases rise and rise and
rise in the surrounding areas the rally
itself was just an absolute absolutely
disgusting combination of red meat and
dog whistles and fear-mongering combined
with lies and a donald trump was
determined to keep it going so on July
3rd Donald Trump did an event at Mount
Rushmore and this was one where social
distancing would not be allowed they
actually zip tied the chairs together so
people were not able to spread the
chairs apart there was barely a mask in
sight and unfortunately after all of
this build up this was one of Donald
Trump's worst speeches and again I sort
of grimace at even calling it that
incredibly low energy this was what
we're calling remember upper and downer
Trump I'm now calling it adderal Trump
and benzodiazepine Trump
this was benzodiazepine Trump a very
very low-energy Trump a glitching
noticeably multiple times on certain
words which I will play for you kind of
doing stream-of-consciousness type stuff
it was the verbal equivalent of an ink
blot or Rorschach test maybe the best
way to describe it extremely sweaty
gripping his lectern a white-knuckle yet
the audience was relatively low energy
so let's go through some of this stuff
we're gonna start with the glitches and
Donald Trump's trouble speaking there
was a lot of it he had a major glitch on
Jefferson if you're watching this you'll
see him verbally catch on the word
Jefferson and his right shoulder
twitches again and he seems to do
something very very odd let's take a
look at it a couple of times
Thomas Jefferson a great Thomas
Jefferson Thomas Jefferson a great
Thomas Jefferson so let's pick it up
right after that
Trump was mentioning Thomas Jefferson
essentially to start reading Thomas
Jefferson's biography in total monotone
very very weird part of the speech take
a look
Thomas Jefferson the great Thomas
Jefferson was 33 years old when he
traveled north to Pennsylvania and
brilliantly authored one of the greatest
treasures of human history the
Declaration of Independence he also
drafted virginia's constitution and
conceived and wrote the Virginia statute
for religious freedom just bizarre right
I mean it sounds like Trump is reading
Jefferson's wiki bio
off of off of a prompter the crowd
doesn't care more importantly reading
Tamil Thomas Jefferson's biography has
nothing to do with Trump's failed
governance or policy or anything like it
Trump later mangling the word
totalitarianism calling it
totalitarianism take a look at that this
is the very definition of
totalitarianism and it is completely
alien to our culture and to our values
and it has absolutely no place in the
United States of America Trump again
going with you Lysias s grant of course
still can't say that one take a listen
Alicia says grant abolitionists and many
others and this was actually part of
Trump just naming people this was
remembered during 2015 and 2016 at his
rallies Trump would just read polls now
Trump just naming people during his
events we are the country of Andrew
Jackson ulysses s grant and Frederick
Douglas we are the land of Wild Bill
Hickok and Buffalo Bill Cody
we are the nation that gave rise to the
Wright brothers the Tuskegee Airmen
Harriet Tubman that went on for a while
I'm not gonna play all of it more
struggles talking continued struggling
with magnificent struggling with
mountain take a look at this be no
better place to celebrate America's
independence than beneath this
magnificent incredible majestic mountain
and monument to the greatest Americans
who have ever lived okay so a lot of
difficulty speaking is the point let's
now get into the meat and the content of
this there's this new strategy that
Donald Trump is employing during his
public events pretend that the left is
some kind of Marxist
fascist nightmare take a look at this
and again very low-energy what he's
saying is crazy but he's delivering it
in this benzodiazepine sort of mode
schools our newsrooms even our corporate
boardrooms there is a new far-left
fascism that demands absolute allegiance
if you do not speak its language
performance rituals recite its mantras
and follow its commandments then you
will be censored banished blacklisted
persecuted and punished it's not going
to happen to us
make no mistake this left-wing cultural
revolution is designed to overthrow the
American Revolution in so doing they
would destroy the very civilization that
rescued billions from poverty disease
violence and hunger and that lifted
humanity to new heights of achievement
discovery and progress to make this
possible they are determined to tear
down every statue symbol and memory of
our national heritage so Low Energy
seems to be on Downer's and the content
Cultural Revolution talking about the
left wants to overthrow the American
Revolution you want to make the United
States just an offshoot and belong to
the United Kingdom I don't see any
leftists who want to do that and just
imagine for a second if a President
Barack Obama or another Democratic
president gave a speech about fighting
the extreme right wing and referenced
defeating Nazis in World War two and
fighting the cold war or whatever as if
that's what's going on today if a
Democratic president did the equivalent
of what Donald Trump is doing here about
Marxism and people who want to undo the
American Revolution Fox News and Rush
Limbaugh and Hannity and Tucker and all
of them they would be going insane for a
week that's essentially what Trump is
doing and you have right-wing
pseudo-intellectuals like rich Lowry
saying this was a great speech if you
can believe that
monuments okay we've learned that Donald
Trump's staff want him to talk less
about monuments because they see it as
kind of a losing approach and again
Trump going on and on here about
monuments he also sounds like he's sleep
talking now it's more like ambien like
it's weird Trump gives an applause line
the audience is almost silence or Trump
just Waits and finally gets some some
reaction from the crowd it's all very
weird our nation is witnessing a
merciless campaign to wipe
about our history to fame our heroes
erase our values and indoctrinate our
children
[Music]
angry mobs are trying to tear down
statues of our founders to face our most
sacred memorials and unleash a wave of
violent crime in our cities many of
these people have no idea why they're
doing this but some know exactly what
they are doing they think the American
people are weak and soft and submissive
wipeouts history and erase our values
how would taking down Confederate
statues erase our values I didn't think
our values were the values of the
Confederacy but maybe among Donald Trump
supporters those values are more common
than than maybe I believe living in
Massachusetts Trump then still seems not
to understand the basics of how a virus
works he talks about killing the virus
of course viruses are not actually alive
let us also send our deepest thanks to
our wonderful veterans law enforcement
first responders and the doctors nurses
and scientists working tirelessly to
kill the virus yeah so on their own
viruses can do nothing until they enter
a living cell like without cells viruses
would not be able to multiply so viruses
are not considered living things Trump
talks about killing the virus who cares
right it's the least of our concerns if
Trump took coronavirus seriously I
wouldn't care if he thought the virus
was a hybrid of a giraffe and a shark I
really wouldn't like if he was actually
dealing with it properly and taking it
seriously
he happens not to be and then lastly
here's another just super low-energy
part where I guess Trump is criticizing
Democrats it's not even clear what the
critique is I guess they're not for law
and order or something and he says kids
are taught to hate their country cities
that are run by Liberal Democrats in
every case is the predictable result of
years of extreme indoctrination and bias
and education journalism and other
cultural institutions
against every law of society in nature
our children are taught in school to
hate their own country and to believe
that the men and women who built it were
not heroes but that were villains so the
audience just barely engaging with what
Donald Trump is saying and this was not
the only horrifying gongshow speech that
Donald Trump gave over the weekend this
was July 3rd in Mount Rushmore on July
4th Donald Trump gave I guess what we're
calling his big 4th of July's speech and
that's what I want to talk about next if
you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time check out one of my
all-time favorite apps called blinka
stinketh lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video